give him a c C+ the G oh he's definitely
an F needs Improvement D plus I get my f
c plus B minus a D minus I'm going to
say f I'll give him a c for 2023 I give
him a c he's done a decent job a B+ I
think think he's tried his best to help
but he's missed the mark especially with
uh student loan forgiveness I need my
student loans forgiven um and I think he
could be doing a little bit more so I
would give him a B+ it seems like he's
not doing anything but pandering to
people that get in his face and it's
wrong he's been doing good but not great
hasn't quite done one thing right didn't
do anything that he was elected on
President Biden should focus on getting
Democrats and Republicans together in
agreement we have to compromise
he should focus on the district there a
lot of crime going on robberies
carjacking it's a lot of stuff going on
with regular people in federal agencies
I think he should focus on uh the little
guys the the the middle class the people
below the middle class and making things
better for us um especially in the city
but he needs to forgive those student
loans that's the first thing on should
be on this
list